you ever watch chills countdown no how
do you how do you knows I don't watch
like ghost this dude talks like
this every single video the number nine
Burger King foot lettuce the last thing
you'd want in your Burger King Burger is
someone's foot lettuce and it's so funny
because every single one some of them
are like really scary and the
voice helps but summer I'm like this
dude is 14 and he says bedroom because
some of the stories are like legit
horrifying and he's like so then they
got killed literally number two they
found him they found his organs
hung up on some like hooks follow me
SoundCloud yeah yeah probably smelled
crazy in there
if you ask me this is gross top 10 of my
own SoundCloud songs